Speaker 1: I can't believe this is happening.
We've joked about this. We were kidding. It
was just a joke. A new report finds that Donald
Trump is considering Carrie Lake to be his vice
president in his 2024 presidential campaign.
I don't know where to start. Axios reports
Scoop Kerry Lake among four women Trump is
considering for VP pick. Former President
Trump is strongly considering picking a female
running mate and sees Carrie Lake as a model
for his vice presidential pick. According
to people who have discussed it with him.
Lake, of course, is the former TV anchor.
She lost her race for governor in November.
Trump believes one of his weaknesses is white
suburban women, that he's going to need white
suburban women to defeat President Biden. And so
the thought is, what about Lake now? What are her
qualifications? Well, Axios, I mean, this isn't
this isn't satire from Axios, but it is a joke in
the sense that it's wild that this is what's going
on. Lake has shown she's willing to defend Trump
vociferously, no matter the issue or controversy.
That's true. She's a true believing sycophant.
That's absolutely true. Trump's friends, to the
extent he has any say that Carry Lake, has a big
downside. He wants no risk that is running running
mate could outshine him, and Lake would be assumed
to be angling for president from the day she
enters the White House. She even went to Iowa
last month. And of course, losing her winnable
governor's race hurts her mojo. Wow. Now Trump is
considering four women. Who else is there? There's
Nikki Haley, who is running against him. And Trump
apparently believes she won't take any votes from
him. So she's not really a danger. Another idea
is Arkansas Governor Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
who was Trump's White House press secretary.
That's pretty wild. And then fourth is South
Dakota Governor Kristi Noem, who's often mentioned
by Trump confidants. Although I don't know that
she carries the faux gravitas of of of Carrie
Lake. I can't believe this is real life. But
it is true. And, of course, when you step back,
you say she has an unblemished record of never
winning anything. She's a complete Trump suck up.
She lies uncontrollably and constantly. That seems
like it would make her a bad candidate. But that
actually is seen as making her a good candidate.
Now, that being said, I think it's important to
be bearing in mind that Trump could win, could
win with anyone as VP. And Kerry Lake being that
close to the presidency is truly horrific stuff.
So there's two perspectives on this. And this is
the same sort of question that came up during my
interview yesterday with Adam Schiff, which is on
the one hand, you and I look at Kari Lake and we
say, Oh, my goodness, that's more of a joke than
Sarah Palin. It would be terrible for Trump at
the national level. We should hope that he picks
someone as crazy as Carrie Lake. The counterpoint
is Trump could win. And there is going to be no
guarantee if Trump is the nominee, that Trump
will be defeated in November of 2024. Do we
really want to risk Carrie Lake becoming the vice
president and then being a heartbeat away from the
presidency? Because we think it would hurt Trump's
chances? Or is it simply too much risk? Now,
of course, at the end of the day, it's not up to
us. It's up to Republican primary voters. But what
started as a joke, it really was just, oh, you
know, Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Carrie Lake are
angling to be Trump's VP, but it's just a joke.
That's all it is. The insider scoop is that Carrie
Lake is not only being considered. She's only one
of four being considered and quite frankly, seems
to be more of a frontrunner based on her level
of sycophancy than a bunch of these other people.
Truly horrifying stuff. But this seems
to be the direction that Trump is going.